hello grammarians and hello paige hi
david so what are we working on today
so today we're going to talk about the
difference between it's
and it's oh well that sounds real tricky
yeah but
we'll be okay okay
so it's with an apostle we have these
two forms in english and they mean very
different things uh so let's
let's go through them really quick so
it's with an apostrophe is a contraction
right what is it a contraction of it is
or
it has
as in it's a lovely day outside or uh
for it has like it's been it has been
one week since you looked at cheese
sad it's been a sad week what a sad week
as opposed to it can you walk me through
it's so it's is a possessive pronoun
and it's a little confusing because
possessive usually uses an apostrophe
too
but
possessive pronouns
don't use apostrophes
so you would say something like i like
ribeye steak because of its rich flavor
that's a pretty grody looking steak no
pink and green is not how you want your
steak to look
so we'd frankly just use
it's where we would use his or her or
their or our um you would use it's right
it's just that it's not a person so so
if i were asking you can i borrow your
book
that's kind of the same thing as i like
ribeye steak because of
its flavor
right it's it's showing that the flavor
belongs to the stake just like the book
belongs to me right
so flavor belongs to it
book belongs to
you
so this is
the core
distinction is if you're talking about
anything that would
be about possession
you use it's its no apostrophe
if you're trying to contract something
it is or it has like it's a lovely day
outside or it's been one week since you
looked at cheese
then you would use it apostrophe s
because it's a contraction you're trying
to cram more information into this one
little phrase precisely
sweet
that's how you choose between i t
apostrophe s and i t no apostrophe s
you can learn anything dave it out page
out